hello everyone something unbelievable
happened already in round one of the
world blitz championship the three days
of rapid are over now there are two days
of blitz and in first round Magnus
Carlsen is playing the Russian Grand
Master
Ernesto inner Kiev and I really I
thought I've seen everything but in this
game Magnus Carlsen actually loses
because his opponent made an illegal
move and Carson didn't call the arbiter
called her Carlson played another move
and then actually at mesto inner Kiev
who who is the original perpetrator of
the illegal move actually called the
hell called the arbiter and Carlson
loses the game you'll see what I mean
and I was very sad because it's it's
really a great game Carlsen plays with
the white pieces and he employs b4
against the Sicilian I really enjoyed
this and I was very sad when this
happened I mean I used this photo of
Ernesto in Turkey he looks very happy
here smiling and that's exactly how he
looked when he was given an interview
after this game so let's see this beauty
like I said Carlson has the white pieces
and he goes efore we have c5 and now 83
by Carlson and not the immediate before
the one I troll people with this is the
mingori knee variation Knight to c6 and
only now before we have seek after some
before a captures and now Knight
captures Carlson sacrificed as a pawn
and we have d4 already grabbing all this
all the important squares in the center
we have d5 c3 now kicking the knight
Knight to c6 and he captures on d5 Queen
captures tend night to a3 Bishop to a5
and now comes Knight the b5 carsten is
already threatening night to c7 this
will check the king and for the Queen so
this would be very unfortunate for inner
Kiev rocked the ca defending and now
Knight captures on a7 driving back the
sacrificed pawn Knight captures rook
captures and we have E 5 now Knight to
f3 he captures on d4 Knight captures on
d4 and Bishop back to d7 and 9th to b5
Carlson offers the exchange of Queen
so we have Quinn capture skin captures
and Bishop to see six kind of pressuring
that G to pawn but Carlson commonly
plays Bishop to d3 and this is a very
nice move especially for a blitz game if
you capture this pawn then you get rook
to e1 check after King to d8 you get
Bishop to f5 and you lose the rook there
is nowhere for this rook to go if you
try something like for example rope to
c5 you get rope create and this is
checkmate
rook has to go back rook captures this
is checkmate so after Bishop to d3
Bishop to c5 by inner Kiev and now
Causton place rook to e1 check 97 and by
playing Bishop to c5 in that cave is
attacking the rook on a7 and also the
pawn on f2 and the Carson solves this
with Bishop to a3 now you can't grab the
rope if you grab the rook you get rook
captures on e7 can cast a move and now
Knight captures Bishop on a7 and you've
just you're just losing this game as
black so that's from Bishop to a3 but
should captures we have rook captures
and rook to d8 now nice to d4 stopping
the attack from the roof to the bishop
we have Kings to d7 rock back to a7 and
rook HDA again if you go for this G to
pawn it's it's not that easy if you
capture it f3 is coming now the b7 pawn
isn't protected by the bishop anymore
also the King has to be protecting the
night here and if you try and hold on to
that b7 pawn for example rook to b8 I
think comes Bishop check King d8 and now
rook to a two attacking that Bishop on
g2 Bishop to h3 and rook to d2 and in a
blitz game in a Kia was a very long time
his King would be under too much
pressure in this position starter up to
a 7 rook H to e8 developing another rook
we have King to see to getting the King
out of the D file King to c7 and we have
rook the b1 now rook to b8 f3 now not
allowing to capture the G to pawn
anymore and Knight to d5 we have map
captures on c6
King characters on c6 and Bishop to b5
okay this doesn't immediately win the
exchange but Kings to b6 now
Carlson's rook on a 7 is also attacked
and here calls in place rook captures on
b7 and this is basically a winning
position for white you're under check
after we captured the rook it doesn't
really matter either with the king or
with the work for example King captures
simply Bishop captures on e8 this comes
with a discover check from the rockin b1
a king has to move you captured King
characters and after Bishop captures on
f7 you're up to pawns it's a completely
winning endgame for Magnus Carlsen
but the problem is and this is something
I don't think I've ever seen this after
this kink the b6 move Carlson did play
rook captures on b7 with check and in
this position nested inner gift totally
ignored this check and he played night
to e3 and he checked Magnus Carlsen
while he himself was in check and this
was the moment when Carlson should have
stopped the clock and called the arbiter
and say the guy made an illegal move you
know give me my full point but instead
Carlson automatically played King to d3
and after playing King to d3
administering Artyom now called the
arbiter and he said Carlsen made an
illegal move this isn't possible and
because Carlson didn't call the arbiter
cousin in the end lost this game so this
is this is pretty amazing you know both
of them were in time trouble I mean
cousin was a bit better on the clock
inner cave at one point I think he got
down to three seconds you know Kea made
me makes an illegal move he's in check
he checks Carlson and then Carlsen moves
out of check and then Carlsen loses the
game so I'm not sure I'm not sure I've
ever heard of this rule
I mean rules are rules but what a way to
defeat the in the world the world
champion not a bad game by not a bad
game by a Russian Grand Master at Nestor
in archaea and like I said he was very
very happy after this game after while
giving the interview so yeah the moral
of the story
know the rules you know not just the
rules of the chess but also rules of the
of the tournament and of at the time
control you are playing so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon as usual you can check to my
previous videos here I will make
probably both of them from the world
rapid championship and I would like to
thank before guillame and the Larry
Davis for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
once again thank you all and I will see
you soon